I'm joined today by Roger veer who is
the CEO of Bitcoin comm thanks for
taking the time to do this I know what
when we scheduled this it was before
like the craziness of the last 72 hours
so I'm sure you've you've been super
busy for people who maybe aren't
familiar with you you've been involved
in the cryptocurrency space in a number
of capacities dating back years now when
did you first get involved with Bitcoin
in a February of 2011 so we're almost to
seven years full time now and when you
first got involved what was the sort of
problem that you saw an opportunity to
solve with crypto so um I suppose the
problem that I saw is that individuals
don't have control over their own money
and they have to beg for permission from
banks and corporations and governments
to be given permission to be able to
send and receive money with other people
either in their own country or in other
countries and when I read about a
Bitcoin and I understood that it's
impossible for anybody to block you from
sending or receiving any amount of money
with anyone else anywhere in the world
you can do it instantly and basically
for free I knew people were gonna start
using bitcoins money so the mother the
first step was to buy some bitcoins and
the second step was to start investing
in all these different businesses that
would enable it easy they would make it
easy for people to start using Bitcoin
in commerce and here we are today seven
years later and bitcoin is this
worldwide phenomenon that's on every
news channel all the time and you know
it's it's getting a lot of attention for
all of the world and mainly because
people did start to use it as money yeah
and I think you know I've read about
some of the different investments that
you made in different crypto related
startups and companies while that was
going on or I guess just put it a
different way your your personal story
sort of correlates with your involvement
in crypto in an interesting way and I
mean your politics is it fair to say
that you're sort of like a libertarian
anarcho-capitalist type guy politically
sure that the word I prefer the most is
voluntary amines that I think all human
interactions should be on a voluntary
basis or not at all so you shouldn't use
force or fraud when dealing with
human beings and I think just about
everybody agrees to that most the time
just they don't see or recognize some of
these specifics in which one group of
people are using force or fraud against
other people and they don't recognize it
as such but when you point it out to
them then it is that then a lot of
people start to think oh maybe that's
not such a good idea after all so but
yeah all of those terms are pretty
accurate when when it comes to
describing my worldview and is the is
the sort of dynamic by which countries
put in place their currency is that an
example of the force that you're against
or maybe I'm reading too much into the
language there um it's okay for anybody
to issue a currency out into the world
and ask people to use it or allow people
to use it or try to entice people to use
it where I have a really big problem is
when governments forbid other people
from issuing their own currency or
forbid people from using a currency
other than the one that the government's
issuing
I have no problem at all with Starbucks
selling as much coffee as they want to
whoever wants to buy it I would have a
huge problem of Starbucks that nobody
else is allowed to sell coffee and we
have that exact sort of thing going on
traditionally with lots of countries
around the world where they issue one
form of money and they say nobody else
is allowed to use any other form of
money and they we've seen them you know
banned people from using gold or silver
or other things in the past so uh I have
the real problem with with the banning
of competition everybody grows up
knowing that monopolies are bad yet
government has a monopoly on the
production of money and I think that's a
something that should come to an end
we're going to get eventually to Bitcoin
cash which in the last few days has also
been been listed on poin base and sort
of a lot of the recent stuff that's
going on in your past also is your
denial of entry into the United States
at one point although I believe and
you'll correct me if I'm wrong that
since you've been allowed to in the
United States you've renounced your
American citizenship most people who
hear you talking will realize you've got
sort of a normal American sounding
accent in English here you were born in
the United States you're no longer a
citizen I believe you also at one point
did some time in a federal prison a
little under a year for the if I
again if I recall correctly the selling
of explosives talked a little bit about
the background that has led you to you
know post serving some time in prison no
longer living in the u.s. no longer a US
citizen is this a decision you've made
for political reasons or talk about sort
of how you got to where you are now sure
so we should probably go in
chronological order um I definitely was
not born a libertarian or a voluntarist
or anarcho-capitalist or whatever word
you want to use I was born with pretty
mainstream American political views
which was kind of apathetic and just
kind of took for granted that the
garrulous
went around and doing these things and
then I just kind of by chance I picked
up an economics book and I found
studying economics to be really really
interesting and the more economics I
study the more I realized that anytime
the government gets involved in the
economy they're pausing in this
allocation of resources and they're
causing resources that would be used for
one thing to be used for something else
that doesn't create as much wealth in
the world for people all over so if you
look around the world the countries with
the most economic freedom have the
highest standard of living and the
fastest rates of economic growth so one
you know fantastic example in in you
know fairly recent history is East
Germany and West Germany you have the
same culture the same natural resources
just two different forms of government
on one side of the wall you know people
are relatively free and engage in
commerce and build things and relatively
productive because of it they're
producing you know Porsches and Mercedes
and BMWs and people have a good standard
of living on the other side there with
just same people again same everything
just different form of government it's
it's horrible
and the only but that's I mean before we
get too far off track with that I mean
in in terms of a counter example the
Scandinavian countries have a
significantly higher standard of living
than Germany does and I would argue that
by libertarian standards they have far
less economic freedom in the sense that
they do have higher taxes they have more
business regulation they have the
government involved in more areas of
people's lives including education and
health care and yet they still have
standards of living so by that that
that's a sort of disproving
by counterexample the principle you
brought up so there's a fantastic video
and fantastic data and I can't recall
exactly which foundation put it together
but basically they compiled the list of
all the countries in the world and they
ranked them by in terms of economic
freedom and then they ranked them by
standard of living and there is very
very very clearly a correlation which
doesn't necessarily mean it's a
causation but there is an incredibly
strong correlation and I think that
there is causation between those two and
you happy to mail it to you afterward on
the show and yeah we can have a whole
other show at some point it probably
would be another show I mean I think
what I would point out is if you were to
just look at a list of those two factors
you would see that there are countries
that have lack of what you would
describe as economic freedom on the one
hand because they are sort of social
democracies like in Scandinavia you
would have another set of countries that
are basically authoritarian
dictatorships they would both by the
libertarian standard I think not
necessarily have high economic freedom
one would have a very high standard of
living one set the other a very low
standard of living but let's let's at
least couch that for now since I think
we probably would not agree and it's not
sort of our primary primary topic today
but getting back to you no longer at
least the US yeah it gets us back to
that sure so so I I studied all these
economics books and came to these
conclusions wrong a right sure but I was
thoroughly convinced that they work her
correct and I and so Wow
even if the government's just retarding
the rate of economic growth by half a
percent per year you compound that over
a hundred years or the last couple
hundred years and we would have all had
flying cars by now and you know be
living forever and so I wanted to share
these ideas with the world and I thought
the best way to to share these ideas
with the world was to run for California
State Assembly as a libertarian so even
during my political campaign I said if I
were elected I wouldn't accept any
salary whatsoever because lots of people
might not want to pay my salary and I
think the taxation the moral equivalent
of theft you're taking money from
somebody who earned it and giving it to
somebody else who didn't earn it and
it's another thing else we won't agree
on but I won't I won't argue with you
today anyway okay and I I'd love to have
a second edition where we can actually
talk about those things but wrong a
right these are the conclusion
that I came to sure and I was advocating
this position and one thing that maybe
we can't agree on here is and I'm not
sure what year you were born eighty four
five years younger than you I think okay
then maybe you can remember I think it
was in the mid 90s maybe 1994 there was
a church in Waco Texas with a bunch of
you know in my book religious nuts yeah
um and we agree that they were religious
leader we agree on that and I hope that
we would agree that the solution that
the FBI and ATF came up with which was
to burn them all to death inside of
their church even if the parents were
religious nuts that didn't help the kids
one bit at all so even if kids have
religious and that parent's burning them
to death in a church doesn't help them
one bit so I called the ATF and FBI a
bunch of murderers in a reference to
burning to death a bunch of kids in a
church and I think that's a pretty
reasonable position turns out the ATF
and FBI didn't think that that was such
a reasonable position and they didn't
appreciate being called a bunch of
murderers in reference to burning to
death I think it was like something like
fifty something kids that were less than
14 years old so anyhow a really really
horrible part of American history there
so then they wound up looking into me
and seeing I was already somewhat
successful in business at that point and
they tried to figure out what can we
prosecute this guy for so I was selling
a computer parts on eBay back when eBay
was first getting started this was even
before the days of PayPal and in
addition to selling computer parts from
Cabela's Sporting Goods catalog I found
a product called a pest control report
2000 which is basically a firecracker
used by farmers to scare birds out of
their corn fields and I found that you
could sell those on eBay for more than
you could buy them from from Cabela's
and again this was back when he Bay had
a guns and ammo section and you can
literally buy you know ar-15 assault
rifles and whatever else you wanted
right off of ebay so I to hide what I
was doing I wasn't even doing anything
secretly I had a website and was doing
everything I could to market these
anyhow I wound up being the only person
in the entire nation to be prosecuted
for selling those without a permit even
though the company that I was buying
them from had no permit the manufacturer
had no permit dozens of other resellers
dozens of other people selling of them
they had no permit I was the only one in
the entire country prosecuted for son
knows about a permit that the actual
charge was dealing in explosives without
a license
it's worth
pointing out that the crime isn't
dealing in explosives the crime is doing
it without the license or without the
permission slip anyhow I was very
clearly guilty of the law as written I
sold firecrackers I sold explosives
without a license
so I pled guilty to that they told me if
I took it to trial and lost which I
probably would have I would do seven or
eight years in federal prison and if I
signed a plea deal I would do between
eight and fourteen months in prison so I
faced with those two choices it was a
decision I signed a plea agreement and I
wound up doing that ten months in
federal prison and three years of
federal probation the day I was allowed
to leave the country I left the country
and haven't lived in the United States
sense basically because I think I was
treated so incredibly unfairly with that
entire saga and that entire part of my
life and then about four years ago now I
actually renounced my US citizenship so
I'm not even the US citizen anymore
eventually we'll get into the scaling
debate with Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash but
lots of people that are on the opposite
side of you that that argument with me
have been going around spreading this
information clean line banned from the
United States and this and that you know
I mean from what I read you were once
denied entry but have since been in the
United States is that true oh yeah I was
just in the United States like three
weeks ago or four weeks ago I was in LA
and Silicon Valley and I can go to the
US anytime I want for the next eight and
a half years or so and then I just have
to renew my visa again at that point so
let's jump into Bitcoin cash a little
bit I mean you know in preparing for our
interview I reviewed a bunch of the
interviews that that you did with Dave
Rubin with you know a bunch of different
people and in at least one interview you
you became I think irate is maybe even
an understatement very very angry with
the interviewer for me I guess miss
naming Bitcoin cash as B cash and
talking about I'd actually love to
correct correct the reasoning there if I
may so um well it seemed like you
interpreted the naming of that as B cash
as sort of an insult right sure and I he
definitely was pushing my buttons by
calling it a Bitcoin cash B cash because
nobody who actually is involved in the
Bitcoin cash project or anybody who's a
fan of it would ever refer to it as that
but I could handle that what really
pushed me over the edge and really made
me lose my cool and I've since
apologized publicly for it I should
got mad upset over it but he accused me
of paying for a bunch of sock puppet you
know she'll Army's on the internet to
promote Bitcoin cash and I have never
ever ever done anything like that at all
whereas there's lots and lots of
evidence that somebody has been paying
for a giant army to do the exact that
exact same thing but on the other side
of this debate so it really really you
know got me riled up when he accused me
of doing something that I've said
multiple times publicly and I'll say
again right now I never ever ever done
anything like that ever and he had been
pushing my buttons up to that point and
then when he just stated as Ematic
matter if I go like everybody knows that
you're paying for shields on the
internet to shill for be cash it I
snapped and I got out of hand and on my
own YouTube channel Roger beer there's
an apology video in regards to just how
uh how upset I got in that and I
shouldn't have gotten that upset there's
an excuse for that but I'd like to
clarify like if you called Bitcoin cash
be cash I think you're a bit of a jerk
but I can handle that if you if you keep
I'm not alright that that's a completely
unacceptable it's not about right lock
well let's have a conversation I mean
I'd like to keep this in terms that
somebody that knows a little bit about
crypto can understand but not
necessarily people who are experts what
are the sort of operational differences
between Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash that
you believe make the latter a superior a
tool or mechanism or store of value call
it what you will
sure so for the average person out there
that's not you know in deep into crypto
currencies they've just been hearing
about a little bit you have two versions
of Bitcoin other's Bitcoin core and
Bitcoin cash it coin core is slow
expensive to use and incredibly
unreliable your transaction might take
hours days or even weeks or maybe even
never fertile through whereas Bitcoin
cash the transactions are fast cheap and
reliable they always go through right
away they're confirmed the next block
everything works exactly how Bitcoin
core used to work so yeah these two
versions of Bitcoin ones fast cheap and
reliable the other slow expensive and
unreliable you don't have to be a rocket
scientist to figure out which one of
those versions of bitcoin is gonna be
more useful to the public so let's get
into summers I'm sorry I think we
a little connection glitch I thought I
thought you would stop talking I
apologize if I spoke over you there are
there and again I am getting more and
more into this this field but I'm
certainly not an expert by any means in
reading about some of the advantages
that you assert of Bitcoin cash over
bitcoin and reading about litecoin I'm
not able to distinguish whether there
are any advantages to Bitcoin cash over
light coin in terms of the problems
you've identified are there or does
litecoin really do what Bitcoin cash
does Bitcoin cash does all the things
that Lachlan can do and even better and
it has one of incredibly important
characteristics of a currency is the
network effect thanks so Bitcoin cash
has a much much bigger network effect
and litecoin every single person in the
world who is a Bitcoin core holder or a
Bitcoin holder on August 1st then became
a Bitcoin core and the big cash holder
so there are millions and millions and
millions of Bitcoin thresholds all over
the world I don't think there's nearly
as many litecoin hole holders all over
the world world there's much more of
Bitcoin cash coming from merchants than
there are for litecoin and I guess one
part of what we see happening is is the
the creator of light coin had been
sucking up to this team that has been
engaging a bunch of censorship and
supporting Bitcoin core the whole time
so all these Bitcoin core people are
saying just use litecoin they prefer
Bitcoin cash to light coin for those
reasons but but from me I think you
should be free to use whatever currency
you find the most useful so whether it's
Bitcoin core litecoin Bitcoin cash you
know Manero - aetherium take your pick
if it's useful feel free to use it
that's that's what I think in my book
you've taken some heat for for this
phrase Bitcoin cash is the real Bitcoin
and I'd like to explore that sort of a
little bit I mean I think that is it
fair to say that you've asserted that
Bitcoin cash is the real Bitcoin because
you feel that Bitcoin cash more closely
matches the original intent of Satoshi
with Bitcoin sure so there let's say
you've developed 10 different
characteristics that define what bitcoin
is or what the real Bitcoin is the
Bitcoin cash version probably has seven
or eight of those and a Bitcoin core
version is the winner on 2 or 3
so there's not a 100% clear-cut
definition as to which way is the real
Bitcoin but if you read the title of the
original Bitcoin white paper by Satoshi
Nakamoto it's entitled an electronic
peer-to-peer cash system the Bitcoin
core developers and the people that are
supporting Bitcoin core with seg wit and
one megabyte blocks and all that they
openly say that they don't want Bitcoin
to be used to ask cash they only want it
to be used as a store value so if
they're saying it shouldn't be used as
the very thing that's in the title of
the original Bitcoin white paper
describing what the coin is I don't
think they have much of a claim to being
the real true Bitcoin yeah I mean I
think I think the problem is or at least
what I've what I've seen is that there
are people who become confused when they
hear a statement like Bitcoin cash is
the real Bitcoin because what you're
kind of saying is Bitcoin cash is closer
to the original vision of Bitcoin than
what Bitcoin has become but that's sort
of like if I say listen this is what the
Democratic Party used to be and now
what's called the Democratic Party
doesn't really meet the original bullet
points or platform of what it was
intended to be so the whatever other
party's the real Democrats are something
like that I'm I'm kind of creating some
confusion if I say something like that
because someone might say oh if I'm
intending to vote for a Democrat I
should actually be voting for you know
whatever other party there is do you see
how that's a it would be confusing to
some people when they hear a statement
like Bitcoin cash is the real Bitcoin
when their intent might be well I will
even if Roger vir feels that the mission
has separated I'm looking for what you
describe as Bitcoin core like is that at
all do you does that criticism resonate
with you actually I think I'm rather
sympathetic to your first argument that
if something veers away from what its
original foundation found founding
principles were then maybe that's not
the original anymore especially when it
comes to things with like block chains
for a Bitcoin core on cash there that's
this block every single block all up
until a particular block Sontag first
and then only after that point did they
diverge but if you read the definition
and the characteristics of Bitcoin in
the original Bitcoin white paper Bitcoin
cash is much much
more closely aligned with what was
defined as being Bitcoin and the
principles that are guiding the people
that are involved and excited about that
coin cash are much more aligned than the
ones that are the people they're
involved with Bitcoin core and Bitcoin
core is people they openly say that they
wanted to have high fees be slow and
unreliable and not be used as money um
they want to just be a store value and
uh
in my book if it's something is an
electronic cash system you should be
able to go and buy you know coffee and
everything else with it where's the
Bitcoin core supporters openly mocked
the idea of being able to buy coffee
with your bitcoins who says though that
it that they wanted to have high fees
that's not one part I part I've seen I'm
not saying it doesn't happen but I just
have not seen that right so that that
was just shocking to me when I first
realized that these Bitcoin core
developers mainly who work for blocked
stream when when it it became clear to
me that these people openly want high
fees like that was just shocking to me I
got who in their right mind would want
Bitcoin to have high fees but just that
yesterday for the first time Bitcoin in
there to get out to get too terribly
technical there's two parts of the minor
reward for the Bitcoin miners there's
the base block reward and then there's
all the fees that people are used the
big work today for the first part the
fees that the people are paying were
more than the the base block reward that
the miners received and this is were
talked about hundreds of thousands of
dollars at this point and then the
Bitcoin core developers literally we're
talking about you know hey pop the
champagne bottles this is success the
fees are higher than the block reward is
now and to me that's just this giant
incentive to motivate people to use
something other than Bitcoin core and
we're seeing that happen Bitcoin core
used to have basically 100 percent
market share it was like 98 99 percent
market share now it's way less than 50
percent and continuing to decline yeah
although I don't think you know I think
any there was a major first mover
advantage so I think that there's an
almost infinite number of businesses
that have had basically persistently
declining market share over time and you
can't necessarily say that's because
it's a bad product or service I mean
part of it is just first mover advantage
takes that huge market share and
eventually it gets chipped away at yeah
but we kind of saw that this happened
right before eyes with a with Friendster
and MySpace they had this huge you know
huge Network effect and all the users
were there on their platform but then
the platform started to give a bad user
experience it was incredibly slow and
time-consuming to use the sites because
the page load times were forever and
then Facebook was able to come in and
steal the show away from both of those
the same thing is happening with Bitcoin
right before eyes if you have a thousand
one different cryptocurrencies and
Bitcoin core is incredibly expensive to
you slow and unreliable and all these
other cryptocurrencies are offering fast
cheap reliable transactions again it's
not a tough decision as to which one
people are going to use and we have
websites like coinbase
offering full support for Bitcoin cash
blocking the world number one crypto
coin wallet offering full swing cash
Bitcoin calm fully supporting Bitcoin
cash bid paid the number one merchant
processing business in the world
offering full support for Bitcoin cash
that's why I'm son my Bitcoin core for
Bitcoin cash there's absolutely no doubt
in my mind that Bitcoin core has headed
in the wrong direction and by this time
next year Bitcoin core will no longer be
the top crypto point in the crypto coin
ecosystem about that in the last so we
have limited time left and we haven't
even gotten to two this week Bitcoin
cash has been listed on a coin base
which I'm sure is just absolutely
gigantic for Bitcoin cash I don't think
there's any doubt about it
you've been accused of colluding with
CNBC around the timing of the coin base
listing the term insider trading has
been thrown out I saw an interview on
CNBC where you said that I don't
remember the exact way you phrased it
but basically you don't see insider
trading as a crime so let's kind of
start there I mean how major is the coin
base listing what about the allegations
about colluding with CNBC and what did
you mean by insider trading it isn't a
crime so um let's take those one at a
time there corn base listing Bitcoin
cashews is huge it's fantastic for
Bitcoin cash fantastic for the world
coin base has been a fantastic company
helping probably more people in the
world buy their first cryptocurrencies
than any other company in the world so
fantastic job coinbase keep up the great
work I have nothing but great things to
say about them but don't don't mistake
them for a Bitcoin wallet they're a
Bitcoin bank
and understand the difference between
those two things in regards to me
colluding with CNBC it's just the
absolute bunch of nonsense they reached
out to me asked me to beyond and tell
the world about Bitcoin cash of course
I'll do that there was absolutely no
collusion or or anything of the sort
it's just a bunch of people uh
complaining on the internet over nothing
well before before we move on and just
to play devil's advocate a little bit
and you know to do my due diligence the
tweets that the CNBC program that that
you were on that they were sending out
they certainly were not the normal types
of tweets that that program normally
sends out and they seem to have to quote
Alan Greenspan there seem to be some
maybe not a rational exuberance but
certainly exuberance in those tweets
around your appearance and about Bitcoin
cash that's not usually there I mean
that was it was sort of unusual right I
don't know because I don't follow their
Twitter feed could I actually don't
stand all that much time on Twitter okay
but one thing that I unexpected may have
happened and maybe you can see this from
yourself like I've explained the
difference between Bitcoin core and
Bitcoin cash and just as a user would
you rather use the one that's fast keep
and reliable or slow expensive and
unreliable and seems like you're pretty
close uh you know a pretty easy decision
to make there so another one I just have
been genuinely and excited about Bitcoin
cash so they were tweeting about it
you're saying I I think that's part of
it and then the other side of that coin
though is you have all these people
attacking you on Twitter saying all
these crazy things that you know are
true that might make you want to be even
more aligned with the other side and I
have another example of that that just
happened earlier today I gave an
interview to an anti-war radio of Scott
Horton and he reached out to me asked me
to be on and the entire reason he
reached out to me is because a bunch of
these anti Bitcoin cash people out of
the blue and he's just barely on the
periphery of Bitcoin he just has it as a
donation option on his website all these
people started attacking him because he
had it on his way on his website and so
uh they basically pissed him off so much
they said wow you guys hate Bitcoin cash
so much I'm gonna spend some time and
research diamond to reach out to this
guy Roger beer and get him on the show
and hear what he has to say about it so
he never would have even invited me on
to his show if it wasn't for these
people attacking him so maybe that's
what went on with CNBC all these people
started attacking
about Bitcoin cash and they're like whoa
whoa calm down here maybe they decide to
push back a little bit for that reason
but so your position is there was
certainly no collusion and there won't
be like any contacts or connections
between you and anybody associated with
that program that will not discovered or
anything absolutely nothing of the sort
whatsoever okay and then how about
insider trading as an on crime that's
interesting to me because when I when I
heard that I thought well I know that
he's like a libertarian
anarcho-capitalist type guy so maybe he
means in in his worldview it's not
really something that should be criminal
but certainly by the letter of at least
American law which I guess you're not
subject to anymore maybe because you're
not a citizen it certainly is a crime
that people do get in trouble for sure
so so legally speaking insider trading
is a crime and people go to prison for
it all the time legally speaking smoking
marijuana is a crime in lots of places
and people go to prison for a long long
time for it sending people to jail for
smoking a plant that makes them feel
happy it's the police lawyers judges in
law enforcement that are the evil ones
that are committing a crime in my book
by sending those people to jail for
smoking a plant that makes them feel
happy it's the same story with insider
trading there's nothing morally wrong
about insider trading at all and I can
give you an interesting example of this
so let's say let's say you were planning
to sell all your bitcoins on Monday of
this week and then you heard through the
grapevine that Oh coinbase is going to
be listing Bitcoin cash and you'd been
planning to sell your Bitcoin cash and
then you heard this news so you decided
not to sell your Bitcoin cash and so you
decided to take no action whatsoever is
that now insider trading well I mean
here's the thing I think the ideological
problem I have is you know when you
consider how skewed something like stock
ownership is in the United States to
begin with right I do think that it's
okay to say we should try to at least
have a level playing field in terms of
information we're never really going to
have a level playing field in terms of
evenly distributed stock ownership right
because companies have everything from
options to buy back programs rich people
disproportionately owned more stocks so
you're never going to have equality of
ownership in the stock market but let's
at least try to equalize the opportunity
by giving everybody the same information
playing field to play with so that's
where I think it is legitimate to say
that if there are as you know companies
that are publicly publicly listed that
it's okay for them to be under under the
jurisdiction of this law that prevents
insider trading because you are even
further sort of like skewing the playing
field I don't think my economic views
think think to say that that's okay and
I know that that's probably not
compatible with your views sure and I
actually would also disagree because it
causes an economic miss a location of
resources so for example when coinbase
the news broke or even a little bit
before the news broke the Bitcoin cash
price started going crazy if people who
knew in advance that Bitcoin that coin
base was going to be listing Bitcoin
cash people like you've been trading on
it all all along the price wouldn't have
moved at all when the news came out and
actually volatility is is is not fun for
investors they don't want these wild
price swings so like if insider trading
is completely legal when news comes out
from these companies the price the stock
price would hardly move at all so and
that's that's something that's actually
a good thing so at the end of the day I
would refer to anybody - you know works
by Murray Rothbard in regards to why
insider trading it's just a completely
non crime and at the end of the day it's
also not enforced so are we gonna have a
bunch of politicians and police been
going around monitoring every company
and see who says what to who and spying
on everything that everybody does all
the time and if if you you know come
into disfavor they'll toss you in jail
because maybe you said the wrong thing
to the wrong person at the wrong time
that's not the type of society I want to
live in either so I know we're basically
at the end of our time I'd love to just
give you a few rapid-fire questions that
people from the audience submitted just
to get your thoughts
you mentioned a year from now Bitcoin
will no longer be the the most widely
held cryptocurrency what do you see do
you have a price target for Bitcoin cash
for a year out and for Bitcoin that you
would be comfortable telling us I don't
know as far as price points but when you
have versions of cryptocurrencies
Bitcoin core that slow expensive an
unreliable and a bunch of other ones
that are fast cheap and reliable you
don't have to be a rocket scientist to
figure out which one of those is going
to be more popular than a year from now
any ideas on next coins to be listed on
coinbase no idea and I was not expecting
coin base
- listed on the day they did I was
pleasantly surprised but I knew for sure
at some point they were going to list
that they have - it just has too much
utility and too many users and
everything else going for it but the the
day and the hour copy by surprise as
well the I cos that we are now seeing in
greater and greater numbers I think I
read on average I see owes returning I
thought it was twelve hundred percent
but now I I don't remember offhand
what's your sense of the future of the
ICO
um I see us are fantastic right it now
allows anybody anywhere in the world to
become a venture capitalists and invest
in any entrepreneur anywhere in the
world so if you have a good idea you can
now pitch it to the world and and raise
some funds or if you have some extra
funds you can look for good
entrepreneurs to invest them with so
it's a fantastically liberating
equalizing the tool for the entire world
to get involved in so I'm really excited
for them but at the same time you know
buyer beware there's lots of schemes out
for bad investments - so be careful with
your money and the last thing thoughts
on the steam it platform I saw that you
were once on that platform and I've been
posting some of our content there it's
been doing pretty well I find that a
very interesting platform although I
have a lot of the same questions other
people do about sort of its long-term
sustainability do you have any thoughts
on that
um I've used it a little bit I earned
quite a few bitcoins for making a few
posts over there so they've definitely
caught my attention but I don't know
enough about it to have real strong
opinions on its long term viability or
that sort of things but like everything
in the world but you know there's a
thousand experiments be tried and the
best one to rise to the top and people
will start using them alright and then
very last one we've seen over the last
couple months at least that Bitcoin
aetherium and litecoin sometimes on a
few day delay are kind of moving in
tandem do you expect that to continue or
do you think that we will go back to
very very different price moves on those
three coins for the most part a lot of
most of the exchanges have Bitcoin core
as the base traded coin that all the
other coins are traded against which
means that their prices will kind of
follow into sync with each other and I I
think that will continue for a while
though one really fun developments that
a bunch of exchanges are now listening
Bitcoin cash as the base pair that
all the other pairs are created against
and that'll be make for some really
interesting dynamics coming up here in
the future all right Roger veer CEO of
Bitcoin comm really appreciate you
talking to me today thank you so much
for having me on